Hi, Micheal.
>> Hi, Charles.
How's it going?
>> It is going quite fine.
How's it going with you?
>> Well this seems really exciting
it looks like maybe you're going to
drive the next lesson.
>> I am going to drive the next lesson,
and the next lesson is
called Game Theory Three.
>> Game Theory Three.
I feel like that presupposes the
existence of Game Theories One and Two.
>> We have in fact done
Game Theories One and Two,
we did it in the last class.
And so there's no point in
doing it all over again.
>> [LAUGH] Okay but
maybe people don't remember all of that.
>> Well I'm sure they
don't because I don't so
maybe what we should do is we should
do another Scooby Doo flashback.
>> Ahh, and
we can do this in a super special way.
>> Because?
>> We're actually in the same
place at the same time.
>> Yeah.
It's crazy.
>> When's the last time that happened?
>> Yesterday right.
That's true, but
this is the first time we're actually
recording something like this that we
are able to actually do that in a way
that it makes sense that the people.
>> Good.
>> So let's do this go to flash we're
going to do it together.
>> Sure.
>> Let's do it together, okay.
You ready?
>> Uh-huh.
>> All right.Okay.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[NOISE]